[Music]
hello you're doing well
most of us fairly disappointed that
child just walked on stage he didn't
even like home alone but he was dying on
23 which is weird
being young doing stand-up comedy kind
of stuff holder comedians can do you'll
see all the comedian's that come onstage
and brag about having sex with women
half their age tends to be frowned upon
really I moved out last year that's a
big step in my life moving out for the
first time it's very hard when you move
out not just hard new hard and parents
as well
sorry not parents parent whenever a
child moves out there's always one
parent that cares and the other one may
I'll see if you can guess which one of
my parents was more upset when I moved
out you've always got two choices
you've got my loving caring friendly
beautiful mother boy or my stepdad now
I'll give you another clue he's not
actually my stepdad I just call him that
- pit em all
if you ever need to know how difficult
it is being a parent ask any parent they
will happily tell you my parents were
always the other thing you just don't
know you don't know the love that you're
capable of feeling until you hold that
baby in your arms do you think you know
love you don't know love not until
you've held that baby in your arms you
don't know the fear you don't know the
fear that you're capable of feeling if
you think your child's gone missing
even if it's just for a second but if
it's just for a second
you can't fathom the fear you feel but
you think your child's gone missing yes
I can I imagine it feels exactly like
this moment what yeah Brian's coming I
don't know I'll call him I'll call him
Oh
my life was near an elevator there's no
way I could have possibly gone on
because losing your phone is worse than
losing a child because if you lose your
child at least you still have the photos
and you can make another baby I can't
get drunk and accidentally make an
iPhone that's never happened it takes
nine months to make a baby I've got 14
months left in my contract
okay my mom said four kids you can tell
that she loves us all the same bar for
the first two she kind of stopped caring
she'll always gonna be she was blessed
with me then she was gifted with my
sister then she had my brother and
she'll always remember the day that she
was diagnosed with the other one we were
all in tension although which is good my
mum's has a very healthy elder to
contraception which is great because her
sister is anti-abortion which is a cruel
nickname but she's had five I'm a
surprised to see whether they let me do
that joke
[Applause]
I know I'm shocked I'm single as well
because I know it's don't lie to me I'm
a terrible boyfriend like they always
have to do the things when you're in a
relationship for example telling a girl
that she's the most beautiful girl in
the world
I never told my ex-girlfriend that she
was the most beautiful girl in the world
and that was for personal reasons it's
because she wasn't no Ana by the way she
was very good-looking but my logic is
there are 3.5 billion women on earth
there can be only one most beautiful
girl in the world that's how it works
that's what that means so all I'm saying
is that statistically probably wasn't
her okay she was livid right she stormed
out halfway through my PowerPoint right
just left crying and phoning her mum
it's the same reason I've never bought
my mom one of those mugs that says
world's best mum because she's not she's
a good mom she's a fantastic mom I love
my mum to bits
Baha there are mothers in Africa who
travels 17 miles every day carrying
litres of water on their head just to
get their kid something to drink
now I visited home two weeks ago and my
mom made me go to the shop to buy some
milk
[Music]
she's just not trying thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]